[Musik]
ein schritt in richtung frieden nach
langen verhandlungen tauschen russland
und die ukraine 70 gefangene aus echte
hilfe oder bloss symbolisch 7 amazonas
staaten schließen einen pakt zum schutz
des regenwalds die spezielle art zu
lernen
deutschlands waldorfschulen feiert ihr
100 jähriges bestehen
die nachrichten nicht dass heute mit
christian sievers guten abend in aalen
schön dass sie bei uns hinter diesem
samstagabend geben sie uns 20 minuten
wir geben ihnen den nachrichtenüberblick
norbert lehmann hat nachher den sport
sehr gerne genannt doch von mir
es soll ein wichtiger schritt sein um
den konflikt zwischen russland und der
ukraine zu beenden heute haben beide
länder gefangene ausgetauscht die größte
aktion dieser art seit jahren
von jeder seite 35 menschen deren
freilassung die jeweils andere zum teil
lange gefordert hatte im osten der
ukraine kämpfen seit jahren von russland
unterstützte separatisten und
ukrainische regierung truppen
gegeneinander
bei den gefechten die bis heute andauern
kamen nach uno angaben mehr als 12.000
menschen ums leben ein weiterer
schauplatz des konflikts die halbinsel
krim 2014 von moskau annektiert russland
will fakten schaffen am und im schwarzen
meer
jetzt aber gibt es vorsichtige hoffnung
dass beide seiten aufeinander zugehen
christian senn berichtet emotionen auf
dem rollfeld applaus und freudentränen
am flughafen in kiew der ukrainische
präsident selensky und angehörige nehmen
die ausgetauschten ukrainischen
gefangenen in empfang
zielinski und russlands präsident putin
hatten direkt über den austausch
verhandelt
wir haben uns geeinigt dass das die
erste stufe eines dialogs ist und der
erste schritt um den krieg zu beenden
an bord der maschine auch der
ukrainische regisseur oleg sind soft er
war wegen angeblicher terroristische
aktivitäten zu 20 jahren haft verurteilt
worden
und 24 ukrainische seeleute russland
hatte sie im november letzten jahres vor
der annektierten halbinsel krim gestoppt
und festgenommen
alles ist gut ich bin glücklich zurück
zu sein
ich hoffe jetzt wird alles gut ich danke
allen die uns unterstützt haben
präsident selensky kann den geglückten
austausch als politischen erfolg
verbuchen
auch russland spricht von einem
wichtigen schritt hoffnung auf frieden
es könnte der anfang sein für
verhandlungen für friedensgespräche über
die ost ukraine und über die situation
der krim
zur gleichen zeit heute in moskau die
andere seite des austauschs auch 35
russische gefangene sind zurück in
russland unter ihnen auch wladimir
seemacht hier im weißen t-shirt
er steht im verdacht am abschuss der ma
17 maschinen in der ost ukraine vor fünf
jahren beteiligt gewesen zu sein und war
jetzt teil des deals 298 tote hat es
damals gegeben beim abschluss von emh 17
schauen wir uns diesen herren noch mal
genauer an dem wir gerade im film
gesehen haben christiansen in moskau
niederländischer ermittler wollten auf
keinen fall dass er frei kommt warum hat
die ukraine ihnen jetzt doch
freigelassen ja es war immer ein
zentrales versprechen des neuen
ukrainischen präsidenten wladimir selent
ski dass die ukrainischen seeleute nach
hause kommen als die russische seite
dann den verdächtigen vom ma 17 absturz
auf die liste gesetzt hat und die
niederländischen ermittler davor gewarnt
haben ihn an russland abzugeben
brasiliens gehen der zwickmühle musste
er sich entscheiden ob er auf der einen
seite entweder die niederländer
verärgert oder eben seinem versprechen
nachkommt und die ukrainischen seeleute
nach hause holt wenn da wenn er das
nicht gemacht hätte wäre der deal
womöglich geplatzt also hat er sich für
die variante entschieden hat heute aber
auch noch mal betont das niederländische
ermittler in der ukraine waren
und bevor dem 8
nach russland ausgeliefert wurde also im
rahmen dieses gefangenenaustausch wurde
er nochmal befragt insgesamt kann man
sagen sind beide seiten sehr zufrieden
mit dieser einigung und die hoffnung ist
jetzt bei vielen groß dass daraus mehr
wird die hintergründe aus moskau
christiansen herzlichen dank und damit
nach deutschland ist es nur eine und
zwar die dritte von 23 spd
regionalkonferenzen aber eben die erste
im osten in bernburg in sachsen-anhalt
die kandidatinnen und kandidaten für den
parteivorsitz wurden dementsprechend auf
ihre ost kompetenz hin abgeklopft also
gleiche löhne jobs in kohle revieren und
die digitale grundversorgung klaus
brodbeck war dabei der erste auftritt
der kandidaten im osten und alle hatten
sich darauf vorbereitet keiner
westdeutsche politik sondern wir wollen
eine politik für ganz deutschland machen
und dafür stehen wir als ost west team
ich habe nämlich keine lust dass man
weiter sich um den osten kümmert ich
möchte dass der osten auf augenhöhe mit
spricht und dass wir klar machen
diese spd das ist keine westdeutsche
erfindung wir sind eine partei die in
allen fünf aus deutschen bundesländern
mitregiert das sollen im westen erst mal
nachmachen
auch dies gehört dazu kampfansagen
gegend ganz rechts
ich kann es nicht ertragen dass die
hippies und gauland die stradivari es
unter den braunen arschgeigen dass die
so tun als würden seine
arbeitnehmerfeindliche politik machen
können erst ruhen wenn ich wieder weg
sind die dürfen in deutschland nicht
gestalten und nie wieder einfluss haben
menschen die irgendwann nazis keine
angst haben müssen
da stehen sozialdemokraten in der ersten
reihe es ist eine ringen um die
ausrichtung der spd
lasst uns unsere partei gemeinsam wieder
stark machen zu einer zu einer starken
und vor allem zu einer mutigen kraft die
progressiv vorangeht und die wieder für
gerechtigkeit für die menschen in diesem
land steht wir müssen den köpfe
investieren in köpfe der jungen menschen
aber auch der die in der mitte des
lebens stehen und nicht mehr so genau
wissen was würde eigentlich mit meinem
beruf habe ich morgen noch arbeit und es
geht natürlich um die frage wie weiter
mit der groko meine
ähnliche einschätzung ist es kommt auf
uns an und unsere stärke und nicht auf
die parteien mit denen wir zusammen
reagieren das ist aus meiner sicht die
entscheidende aussage nichts davon wird
uns jemals in der großen koalition
gelingen
daher sollten wir die verlassen das
empfehlen wir den mitgliedern die spd
sucht eine neue spitze und irgendwie
auch sich selbst
[Applaus]
viele menschen trauen uns nichts mehr zu
aber da vorne stehen leute die ideen
haben und dass man zwar nach draußen
tragen
ich fange damit morgen an es ist ein
politiker tun noch ohne klaren favoriten
der iran hat einen weiteren schritt raus
aus dem internationalen atom abkommen
gemacht und bereits stillgelegte
zentrifugen zur urananreicherung wieder
in betrieb genommen
der chef der iranischen atombehörde
sagte diese schritte seien noch
umkehrbar den europäern bleibe aber
nicht mehr viel zeit den atomvertrag zu
retten
die usa hatten ihn einseitig gekündigt
und sanktionen gegen teheran verhängt
jörg brase gaszentrifugen wie diese
benötigt man zur anreicherung von uran
man habe die bestehenden zentrifugen
wieder in betrieb genommen verkündete
der sprecher der iranischen atombehörde
heute in teheran
man sei nun in der lage größere mengen
uran in höheren grad anzureichern
damit entfernt sich iran weiter aus dem
atom abkommen wenn die anderen
vertragspartner ihre verpflichtungen
wieder einhalten werden auch wir das
wieder tun
bis dahin aber gehen wir unseren weg
weiter die europäer sollten wissen dass
nicht mehr viel zeit bleibt wenn sie
etwas unternehmen wollen sollten sie das
schnell tun
iran erhöht den politischen druck auf
die europäer reagierten gereizt
wir haben ganz klar und eindeutig gesagt
dass unsere verpflichtungen davon
abhängen dass sich iran weiter
vollständig an das abkommen hält
durch die neuen maßnahmen will teheran
erreichen dass iran wieder öl verkaufen
und geld verdienen darf den harten kurs
ihrer regierung unterstützen fiel die
europäer handeln doch auf befehl der
amerikaner
wir müssen unser eigenes ding machen
irans regierung lavieren zwischen den
eigenen religiös konservativen
hardlinern und den europäischen
vertragspartnern bei dem jetzt
verkündeten dritten schritt heraus aus
dem atom abkommen wurde ganz bewusst
darauf verzichtet konkrete zahlen zu
nennen
zb für den anreicherungsgrad von uran es
ging darum den druck aufrechtzuerhalten
und zeit zu gewinnen nicht die tür für
verhandlungen zuzuschlagen
um die folgen der wirtschaftssanktionen
auszugleichen legte frankreich den plan
for iran einen öl kredite in milliarden
höhe zu zahlen wurde das gelingen könnte
teheran bereit sein sich wieder an das
abkommen zu halten
mindestens 43 tote niedergerissen häuser
weggeschwemmt straßen die bisherige
bilanz von hurrikan dorian ist
verheerend als abgeschwächter
wirbelsturm zieht dorian gerade in
richtung kanada
das schlimmste scheint vorbei viele
menschen auf den bahamas aber stehen vor
den trümmern ihrer existenz und wollen
nur eins ihre zerstörte heimat verlassen
peter jäger und el mati wissen berichten
am dock von marsh harbour steht militär
damit nicht alle gleich losstürmen wenn
ein boot eintrifft hurrikan dorian war
schon schlimm genug nun ist das warten
unerträglich für die menschen auf abaco
island der premierminister in
erklärungsnot warum ist tage dauert wir
können euch nicht alle gleichzeitig
holen aber boote werden kommen boote und
flugzeuge
die zerstörung ist vollständig viele
hier brauchen psychologische betreuung
ich mag's habe gibt es nicht mehr unser
haus weg alles weg die ärmsten von abaco
haben am meisten verloren hier standen
vor dem hurrikan noch ihre holzhäuser
davon ist nichts mehr übrig das ganze
gebiet ist zerstört und die menschen
hier erwarten auch dass sich die zahl
der todesopfer noch weiter erhöhen wird
in den trümmern suchen sie nach essbarem
immer wieder finden sie verletzte und
tote hierher zum flughafen von nassau
werden die opfer gebracht hier gibt es
auch den sammelpunkt an dem angehörige
auf nachricht warten es kann wochen
dauern bis sie klarheit haben es ist
eine herausforderung es ist ein sehr
verteiltes land eine kleine bevölkerung
aber wir haben rund 700 inseln verteilt
über 260.000 quadratkilometern mehr
kreuzfahrtschiffe steuern die bahamas an
spenden nahrungsmittel nehmen
flüchtlinge an bord aber sind zu viele
menschen die darauf warten dem nichts zu
entkommen immer nur ein paar so lange es
dauert und mehr als 3000 kilometer
weiter südlich hatten die gigantischen
waldbrände in südamerika weltweit
bestürzung ausgelöst und große sorge die
weltbank um den amazonas regenwald jetzt
wollen sich 7 angrenzende länder
gemeinsam für den schutz des gebiets
einsetzen
das haben die staatschefs beschlossen
beim amazonas gipfel in kolumbien
erstmal ist es ein stück papier ob es
etwas bewirken könnte erklärt unserer
südamerika korrespondent christoph haker
rat
große caro
[Musik]
vater der wald ist kein wald mehr
ecuadors präsident moreno singt seinen
kollegen ins gewissen gipfeltreffen in
südamerika sind anders ohne pathos geht
es nicht die staatschefs der amazonas
länder sonst selten einer meinung wollen
ein zeichen setzen für den schutz des
regenwaldes
aufgrund unserer ideologischen
differenzen mögen wir bei vielen themen
auseinander seien aber die rechte von
mutter erde stehen wahlen was mit dem
amazonasgebiet geschieht betrifft nicht
nur unsere staaten
es betrifft die ganze welt das treffen
vor passender kulisse im kolumbianischen
letizia hat vor allem symbol wird und so
überrascht es kaum dass ausgerechnet
brasiliens rechtsextremer präsident ball
szenario gar nicht lässt erscheint
sondern einen vertreter schickt per
videoschalte beschwert er sich über ein
mischung aus europa und sagt worum es
ihm bei den pakt geht unsere
souveränität über das gebiet ist nicht
verhandelbar
am ende unterschreiben sie alle auch
brasilien
doch sehr konkret ist der pakt nicht
keine bindenden verpflichtungen keine
zahlungen nur die absicht den wald
gemeinsam besser zu schützen
es ist ein anfang mehr aber nicht es
darf keine ausbeutung mehr geben keine
zerstörung von mutter erde
denn mutter erde ist müde etwas
entspannung bringt vorübergehend der
regen der gerade über zentral brasilien
zieht doch weite teile des waldes
brennan weiter
illegale abholzung und umweltzerstörung
themen die auch der papst immer wieder
in den mittelpunkt stellt dieses mal auf
madagaskar der zweiten station seiner
afrika reise
dort hätten vor allem die armen oft
keine andere wahl als wälder abzuholzen
um zu überleben sagt franziskus er
kritisiert spekulation und korruption
würden die ungleichheit der
lebensbedingungen erhöhen
madagaskar gehört zu den ärmsten ländern
der erde
die online enzyklopädie wikipedia ist
ziel eines großangelegten hackerangriffs
geworden neun stunden lang war wikipedia
nicht zu erreichen
betroffen waren alle sprachversionen
weltweit
dabei wurde die datenbank mit riesigen
mengen unsinniger anfragen lahmgelegt
ein anonymous hacker kollektiv hat sich
zu der tat bekannt
und für heute abend einen weiteren
angriff angekündigt
es gibt viele klischees die sich mit der
waldorfschule verbinden auch viel kritik
aber heute zunächst mal ein jubiläum die
waldorfschule feiert ihren 100
geburtstag
diese schule hier in stuttgart war die
allererste heute lernen allein in
deutschland rund 88.000 kinder und
jugendliche an insgesamt 245 freien
waldorfschulen das ziel die schüler nach
ihren individuellen talenten fördern
auf dem stundenplan stehen deshalb auch
fächer wie gartenbau handarbeiten und
europa also die kunst sich zu bewegen
kein schüler bleibt sitzen und noten
vergeben die lehrer erst in höheren
klassen sven class berichtet
französischunterricht dritte klasse so
sieht das an der waldorfschule aus ohne
schulbuch dafür mit viel bewegung mit
rollenspielen mit musik so lernt es sich
am besten
sind sie an waldorfschulen überzeugt die
schüler haben die möglichkeit richtig
einzutauchen durchsprechen durch bewegen
durchs tanzen in die sprachen jeweilige
kultur nicht der stoff sondern die
schüler sollen im mittelpunkt stehen
ihre individuellen bedürfnisse und
interessen ein kernelement der
waldorfpädagogik die erste waldorfschule
vor 100 jahren gegründet in stuttgart
vom besitzer einer zigarettenfabrik
zunächst für die kinder seiner arbeiter
grundprinzipien bis heute es gibt kein
sitzenbleiben lange keine noten
umstritten
weitere kritik walldorf unterricht sei
esoterisch und weltfremd digital
hinterher
man hört sogar spieler sind ja dumm oder
so und ich bin zwar komisch weil wir
machen am ende genau denselben abschluss
dennoch ist das spezielle pädagogische
konzept sicher nicht für alle
gleichermaßen geeignet ein konzept das
über jahre ohne leistungsdruck arbeitet
das davon ausgeht dass jedes kind von
sich aus lernen will und doch machen
waldorfschüler laut experten am ende
sogar öfter das staatliche abitur als
der durchschnitt sind oft auch im
berufsleben erfolgreich
sie wählen dann später oft andere berufe
spezifische berufe im sozialen feld die
medizinischen therapeutischen und im
künstlerischen fällt man könnte auch
sagen sie wählen berufe in denen sie
meinen sich stärker selbst verwirklichen
zu können
in stuttgart wo alles los gegen feiern
sie den geburtstag der ersten
waldorfschule auch mit schülern aus
aller welt
denn inzwischen gibt es waldorfschulen
auf allen kontinenten und aus der schule
jetzt zum ernst des lebens hier ist der
sport wird zum ernsten fußballspiel von
gestern nahmen deutschland niederlande
die erste deutsche niederlage in der
fußball em quali eine deutliche
niederlage 24 eine verdiente niederlage
oranje war klar besser und ein spiel mit
folgen verteidiger nico schulz fällt
verletzt für die partie am montag gegen
nordirland aus die fenster
mannschaftshotel waren freundlich zu
sehen waren ohnehin nur spieler die
gestern fast oder gar nicht gespielt
hatten trotzdem ist es dann irgendwann
kein zufall mehr wenn das drei spiele
nacheinander passiert dass man eine
führung her gibt und wir es dann nicht
schaffen ball und gegner zu
kontrollieren
die frühe führung durch gabri war der
lichtblick im klassiker gegen die
niederlande im ausverkauften
volksbank-stadion aber der bundestrainer
bekam auch viel schatten zu sehen vor
allem die fehleranfälligkeit der
defensive führte gleich zu vier
gegentoren in der zweiten halbzeit so
was hat schon lange nicht mehr gegeben
das selbstbewusstsein heute hatten wir
nicht in dem maße wie die spiele davor
nun wird der wind rauer in hamburg noch
nicht aber montag abend in belfast ganz
sicher und mehr zur fußball em
qualifikation natürlich im aktuellen
sportstudio um 23 uhr zu gast der
ehemalige niederländische
nationalspieler rafael van der vaart und
der deutsche sport kletterer und vize
weltmeister
alexander megos ferrari-pilot charlie
claire startet morgen beim großen preis
von italien in monza von der
poleposition vor weltmeister lewis
hamilton nach einem chaotischen
qualifying glück gehabt ferrari ist
neuer liebling im gespräch mit dem
zweitschnellsten lewis hamilton
erklär gelingt wie dem mercedes piloten
auch die beste leistung zu beginn des
dritten qualifying teils das reicht
normalerweise nicht zum ende wird noch
mal angegriffen aber ein monster braucht
man windschatten um schnell zu sein
keiner will vorne weg fahren und dann
passiert das links oben läuft die uhr
runter auf null
das feld erreicht die ziellinie zu spät
um noch eine schnelle runde zu fahren
keiner verbessert sich sebastian vettel
bleibt nur rang vier
das nicht versuchen zu erklären
natürlich es ist schwachsinnig aber kann
man sagen ohne windschatten die runde zu
starten ist genau so irrsinnig den
tifosi ist das egal hauptsache am ende
ist ein roter vorn
die deutschen basketballer haben ihre
chance auf die olympia teilnahme bewahrt
zum auftakt der platzierungsrunde bei
der wm in china besiegte das team
senegal mit 89 zu 78 und trifft am
montag auf kanada
bester deutscher werfer nbs da dennis
schröder mit 24 drin ist drin ist für
die meisten regnerisch für einige aber
auch sonnig so wird der sonntag wichtig
dabei nächste woche deutet sich schönes
spätsommerwetter an freuen sie sich also
auf katja horne vergleich und mehr
hintergründe und reportagen hat marietta
slomka im heute journal um 22 uhr 45
danke fürs zuschauen das morgen wünschen
allen einen angenehmen samstagabend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren in
den vergangenen drei monaten hat es in
deutschland viel zu wenig geregnet
mit einer ausnahme am alpenrand und
genau dort regnet es in den nächsten 24
stunden mit dem tief hans sehr ergiebig
anfang der woche kommt dieser regen aber
endlich auch im nordosten deutschlands
an 50 bis 70 liter regen pro
quadratmeter sind da durchaus möglich
heute nacht regnet es zwischen dem
schwarzwald und im allgäu und zwischen
der mosel und der nordsee sind einige
regenschauer unterwegs es bildet sich
auch mal nebel bei temperaturen von 12
bis 5 grad
morgen bleibt es für uns meist stark
bewölkt bis bedeckt und es fällt vor
allen dingen südlich der donau viel
regen deutlich freundlicher sieht es
zwischen dem erzgebirge und der
lüneburger heide aus da zeigt sich
nämlich mal die sonne und dort steigen
die temperaturen immerhin auf 19 bis 20
grad sonst gibt's 15 bis 16 grad im
dauer grau an den alpen bleibt es
allerdings bei 9 bis 13 grad
am montag regnet es dann noch ganz
ergiebig im osten und vor allen dingen
auch im nordosten deutschlands bei
temperaturen von elf bis 18 grad dann
aber setzt sich von südwesten immer mehr
schönes spätsommerwetter durch schönes
wochenende